this winter in Paris the climate summit
the goal a legally binding universal
agreement to halt global warming Candis
unlikely heroes save our planet India
weakness almost 400 million citizens
without electricity strength access to
cheap a dirty coal China witness the
world's biggest carbon emitter strength
a pledge to cut carbon emissions big
time the u.s. weakness uncooperative
Congress strength a committed president
to succeed these countries along with
the rest of the world will need to
combine their powers to attack climate
change on two fronts first stop the
earth's temperature from rising more
than 2 degrees Celsius that's the point
where scientists say climate change
becomes catastrophic and second help
countries adapt to a changing climate
poor countries want this to include
money from rich nations who've
contributed the most climate change will
they come to an agreement in time to
save the planet
we are dealing with political leaders
who are will be gathering at the UN on
Tuesday